It's almost time to go.
But before we do,
we love to leave you with a little something
to take on the road with you,
and it's something we like to call it, do it Rossi,
The doggy bag.
And today, it's a handy kitchen Drew bag.
That's right.
It's functional and chic.
It's the bamboo magnetic knife holder.
And for under twenty bucks,
I think even some places sell it for less.
Wow.
Some are more,
you know, depending on who's selling,
and you can get this low profile magnetic strip.
And talk about, you know what,
this is, this Via would approve.
I was just gonna say, talk about a space saver.
You just put this on your wall,
magnets, your knife goes right there. So cool.
It's, it's vertical storage,
such as Via just taught us about.
And I have one at my house that I am in love with.
Yeah, that's right.
Do you see me?
That's me and my new kitchen
that I'm renovating as we speak.
And I bought that and I put all of the knives
that I have on it.
That's so great. I need one of these
for my little kitchen here in New York
'cause I don't have enough drawer.
I have like one drawer.
I also think it's really beautiful and decorative.
Totally. Can I have this one? Thank you.
Yes, you can, Rossi.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Thank you so much to our audience
who might be watching at home
or on the go, or wherever you are.
We are honored that you choose to spend time with us.
We want you to have a fantastic day.
We want you to take all of this goodness with you,
and we hope we get to see you soon.
(upbeat music)